[Music]
on this sunday night sending in
reinforcements
the military and red cross head to
alberta it's welcome and needed but it
might not be enough but is it too little
too late ottawa under fire for failing
to charge a canadian accused of
supporting isis
plus america's battle over abortion
rights nearly 50 years after roe v wade
and the unprecedented demand for
medically assisted death in one canadian
province
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us members of canada's military are
scheduled to arrive in alberta tomorrow
to help the province deal with its
escalating pandemic crisis intensive
care units are double their normal size
and every available resource is going
toward patients with coven 19. but the
delta variant is still surging in this
part of canada and as heather york's
west explains doctors on the front line
say the incoming federal help is not
enough to keep pace with demand
inside edmonton's royal alexandra
hospital the icu is drowning with more
patients than it's ever seen this
reminds me of you know all of these
movie scenes where people are in rooms
with water coming up and treading and
you know there's this point where people
are literally tilting their head trying
to gas the last air in the room that's
where our hospitals are right now except
in emergency cases operating rooms
across the province have gone dark every
available resource dispatched to care
for those sick with covet 19.
it's why alberta has asked the canadian
armed forces for help but the military
doesn't have many resources to give a
team of eight critical care nurses will
arrive in edmonton on monday the red
cross is also preparing to deploy a team
of up to 20 people while a small number
of health workers from newfoundland are
due to arrive in alberta later this week
it's welcome and needed but it might not
be enough for it to be overwhelmed
really quickly so
you know we need to stop our
transmission in cases as well that's
because within the province covet 19
continues to spread
current public health measures including
a vaccine passport system and an indoor
mask mandate has helped new daily case
numbers plateau but that's not enough to
reschedule the thousands of surgeries
canceled over the last few weeks there's
no question a lot of those patients are
declining to the point where now they
present as emergencies i've seen it
myself already i've seen a pediatric who
was waiting and delayed that had to go
be you know rushed to an emergency
surgery for it as an example it's why
many doctors groups including the
canadian medical association have called
for more restrictions including a period
of lockdown for both alberta and
saskatchewan but in an interview on
chorus radio sunday saskatchewan's
premier said that was something his
government is trying to avoid i don't
think everything is ever all off the
table but uh you know a lot lockdowns i
don't think are
are the thing that any government really
is considering at this point in time we
have so many other tools that are
available those tools will need to work
fast to help hospitals across both
provinces paralyzed by covid19 heather
urex west global news calgary
new brunswick is also battling a
record-breaking surge in cases during
this fourth wave this weekend the
province reported over 230 new cases and
six more deaths higher than at any other
time in the pandemic
cases i think this has been the most
deadly week of the pandemic for new
brunswick
uh in the past 18 months
and that is predominantly going to be
unvaccinated people
health officials say 67 of new cases
involve unvaccinated people last month
new brunswick reinstated its state of
emergency and introduced more measures
to help curb the spread of the delta
variant
dozens of people marched through toronto
today to draw attention to ontario's
nursing shortage
[Applause]
healthcare workers are calling on the
doug ford government to do more to hire
and retain staff the canadian federation
of nurses unions estimates there are
more than 16 000 vacancies across the
province frontline workers say the
shortage is impacting patient care
if you need that ecg or that blood work
to see if you have a heart attack and it
takes instead of half an hour an hour it
takes four or five hours that has real
implications and we're starting to see
that people having heart attacks in the
waiting room that are not being
addressed and treated adequately
the nurses are calling on the province
to provide fair pay safe working
conditions and repeal bill 124. the
legislation was introduced in 2019 and
caps certain public sector wages and
benefits and an annual increase of one
percent
justin trudeau has apologized for taking
a vacation with his family instead of
attending events on the first ever
national day for truth and
reconciliation the prime minister's
office says he spoke on the phone with
roseanne casimir the chief of
tekemploops to schwepnick the first
nation had extended two invitations for
trudeau to join residential school
survivors and their families in kamloops
bc on thursday
that same day a global news camera
captured trudeau walking on the beach in
tofino on vancouver island according to
the pmo trudeau told kasamir he would
visit kamloops soon something he has yet
to do since the discovery of suspected
unmarked graves at the city's former
residential school
there are questions for the federal
government as to why u.s authorities and
not the rcmp have detained a canadian
who admits to being a fighter for the
so-called islamic state muhammad khalifa
is in fbi custody charged with a
terrorism offense as david aiken reports
national security experts say this
development hurts canada's international
reputation
muhammad khalifa is a canadian
he was an i.t worker in toronto before
ending up in syria fighting with isis he
was captured by kurdish forces in early
2019 and when global news interviewed
khalifa in syria in october 2019 he
admitted to being the narrator of isis
execution videos my goal was basically
just to join
the fight in syria
khalifa was the voice for example behind
the infamous flames of war video a video
which ended with isis members executing
their victims this harshness never
wavered
and was a constant trait of the brothers
the 38 year old now stands accused of
conspiring to provide material support
or resources to a foreign terrorist
organization but he is not being accused
of that crime by any canadian authority
instead it is the fbi who took custody
of khalifa from those kurdish forces and
now khalifa will face trial in an
american courtroom this is the first
time we've heard of a canadian being
prosecuted by a foreign state for their
role in isis abroad for national
security experts like west the fact that
americans are prosecuting a canadian
means canada's credibility as a partner
in the global fight against terrorism is
taking a hit our reliability
in the fight against bringing terrorists
to justice is pretty much nil right now
the rcmp have said traveling to northern
syria has been too dangerous for their
investigators but west was able to join
global news journalists who traveled to
the same region to interview khalifa and
other isis members detained by kurdish
forces certainly at the time that i went
there was no indication that
in my experience that
consular services
could not be provided
public safety minister bill blair's
office said sunday it is aware of
khalifa's case but could not explain why
khalifa will not have to answer for his
actions in a canadian courtroom
david aiken global news ottawa
in afghanistan at least five people were
killed in a bombing outside a mosque in
kabul the explosion happened during a
funeral for the mother of the taliban
spokesperson all of the dead were
civilians who were outside the gates
where the bomb went off more than 30
others were injured no one has claimed
responsibility though several recent
attacks have been carried out by the
islamic state offshoot known as isis-k
tomorrow the nine justices of the u.s
supreme court will reconvene for a new
session the court which now leans
sharply conservative kicked up a
firestorm last month when it declined to
block a texas abortion law from taking
effect this fall it will hear a case
that takes direct aim at the landmark
roe v wade decision jennifer johnson
reports
outside the u.s supreme court riot
police stood between protesters for and
against abortion rights on monday the
high court begins one of its most
controversial sessions ever a
republican-led state is asking the court
to overrule the constitutional guarantee
of abortion established nearly 50 years
ago in roe v wade if we're really
marching for women's rights we shouldn't
exclude the preborn from that all over
the country this weekend women marched
for their right to abortion as more than
a dozen u.s states moved to make access
to abortions more difficult a huge
pro-choice rally was held in austin
texas one month after the governor
signed into law the most restrictive
abortion law in the country it bans
abortions after cardiac activity in the
fetus is detected around six weeks for
texas the scariest thing is that any
private citizen
can file a lawsuit
who against anybody who assists a person
in seeking an abortion this could be a
friend a provider a nurse
a friend who's driving the person to get
an abortion could potentially be sued
many texas women remain defiant
including this lawyer who continues to
help women get abortions
come sue me i dare you
last month a sharply divided supreme
court refused to block the texas law
from taking effect while legal
challenges go forward but the high court
will hear a mississippi abortion case
december 1st that law bans almost all
abortions after the 15th week of
pregnancy lower courts have not allowed
the law to take effect it will be the
court's biggest test challenging roe v
wade
i cannot believe that we're going back
and erasing all the progress that we've
made over the past half century women
fear this court could be the one to take
away abortion rights six of the nine
judges are conservative the last three
were appointed by former president
donald trump and have publicly expressed
their strong opposition to abortion
jennifer johnson global news washington
there are calls for police reforms in
the u.k after two disturbing cases
involving officers david carrick a
constable with the london metropolitan
police force has been charged with rape
he was in the same unit as wayne cousins
who was recently sentenced to life in
prison for kidnapping raping and
murdering sarah everard as redmond
shannon reports her death has put a
spotlight on how police organizations
investigate their own
the cctv footage released this week is
chilling
a passing bus catches constable wayne
cousins falsely arresting sarah everard
in march in the days after raping and
killing the 33 year old cousins buys
gasoline and rubble to cover up the
horrific crime
a week later his colleagues arrest him
outside the sentencing hearing this week
protests demanding change within the
police i think we're all brokenhearted
and scared and no one cares enough to
make it a fundamental priority
indifference
the court heard colleagues of cousins at
his previous police force knew he was
attracted to violent pornography a
newspaper report said officers nicknamed
him the rapist which police deny and
three incidents of indecent exposure
were allegedly linked to cousins one
happened just three days before the
murder
indecent exposure no one's stopping him
it's like unfathomable i recognize that
for some people a precious bond of trust
has been damaged huge questions remain
about the vetting of cousins and the
lack of any intervention before he
committed the murder and in the
aftermath of his life sentence the
metropolitan police have issued advice
to women on how they should interact
with a lone police officer the force
says if women are unsure they should
shout for help run to a house or call
emergency services women's rights
activists have pushed back saying it's
not the public who should have to change
but the police
we believe that there is a sort of
patriarchal culture within the police
they need to be breaking that down they
also need to be breaking down this
sense of of loyalty
to your fellow officers above loyalty to
justice the mayor of london says
undercover officers must now work in
pairs the crisis in police confidence
and women's increased concerns about
going out at night come at a time when
taxis are harder to come by amid the
uk's fuel supply shortage redmond
shannon global news london
coming up dying on their own terms why
the demand for assisted death is growing
and the lessons in linguistics a rebirth
of indigenous languages that's later on
global national
since this country's assisted dying
program was introduced in 2016 health
canada says almost 22 thousand canadians
have chosen to end their lives on their
own terms federal legislation passed in
march has made the option more
accessible to some canadians and as
rosloid reports demand has been growing
and at least one province can't keep up
there are three months remaining in this
year and nova scotia has already topped
last year's record high number of
referrals for medical assistance in
dying in a province struggling to
provide decent healthcare services the
growing demand for assisted dying is too
much what we're faced with right now is
a a backlog of people who are stuck in
that process who haven't yet been able
to access so we've got people for
example who've
made a referral back in may or june who
haven't been seen yet but who are now
increasingly needing to be seen
there's been a surge in demand since new
federal legislation passed in march the
lawmakers assisted dying more accessible
for some canadians even if their death
is not reasonably foreseeable the big
challenge is finding enough doctors and
nurse practitioners to keep up with that
growing demand professionals who are
already stretched thin by their regular
duties
other provinces could face similar
problems with the group that speaks for
assisted dying assessors and providers
noting applicants are facing an
unprecedented and lengthening waiting
list it does point to
a need to
monitor access across the country and
and for governments to put sufficient
resources
into the system to make sure that these
kinds of delays are not
are not any longer than they have to be
nova scotia health says help is on the
way from a number of new clinicians
expressing interest in contributing and
by hiring a full-time nurse practitioner
to help clear up the backlog that
creates a great deal of stress and
suffering for these people and we want
to accommodate them as best we can
assisted dying now represents 2.5
percent of all deaths in canada analysts
expect it to level off eventually to
between 3 and 4 percent per year
ross lord global news halifax
still ahead an asian country mulls a ban
to take canines out of its cuisine
the consumption of dog meat in south
korea is a centuries-old practice but
this week the country's president who's
a dog lover said it's time to consider
banning it it's welcome news for animal
rights groups crystal gomezing looks at
why the controversial cuisine could soon
be off the menu
happy relaxed and clearly loved loco and
a sally have adjusted to life in quebec
essentially they bring joy i have
grandkids they love the dog
these two are like hundreds of canadian
pets whose lives began much differently
on dog meat farms in south korea
future rescue adoptions may not be
needed
the spokesperson for south korea's
president says the issue has been raised
with the prime minister as the president
feels the time has come to carefully
consider imposing a dog meat ban
it's estimated one million dogs are
slaughtered for food annually but demand
is dropping talk of a ban has gained
momentum as more people get dogs as pets
including the president
i am korean national but i wouldn't say
dogumi consumption is korean culture
because you know culture changes as the
society progresses um these days
especially younger generations we really
don't
need to
consume a dogma really
humane society international has
overseen the closure of more than a
dozen operations where animals were
found malnourished confined in cages and
covered in feces it's absolutely
horrible
ava damienovich has attended seven farm
closures and helped relocate rescued
dogs to the uk the states and canada
knowing that this could be at the end
is the
the the objective that we've had for
years i'm really hoping that this time
it's really going to lead to something
polling done for humane society
international in 2020 showed the
majority of people in south korea
support a ban with no clear timeline the
future of dog meat could end up being an
election issue when a new president is
selected next year
crystal gomenson global news london
finding the words up next the efforts to
save indigenous languages
languages are essential to the culture
of canada's indigenous people especially
since so many first nations were forced
to give them up the younger generations
have little exposure to them and that's
why a winnipeg non-profit is working to
preserve manitoba's indigenous languages
to ensure they'll be passed on here's
marnie blount
a small excerpt of a book in ojibwe
part of something bigger an initiative
ensuring indigenous languages are not
lost through generations if we lose our
indigenous languages it is said that
then the voices of the land will be lost
and i really believe that for grace
schedler growing up in a northern fly-in
cree nation allowed her to be connected
to her language culture and identity i
myself
was lucky to be raised in the language
and in the culture
and when you are raised in a language in
a culture it kind of
paves the way that you
that you grow right you
it guides you as you get older on how
how you live now schedler is helping
ensure other indigenous people have the
opportunity to be fluent in their mother
tongue through the nonprofit
organization indigenous languages of
manitoba it's important for
you know people to understand that they
have a right to learn about their
language and culture preservation of
languages is waning over the years due
to the impact of residential schools
colonialism and intergenerational trauma
i'm very passionate about our indigenous
language and culture
i'm an anishinabe from
indonji
and
especially with everything going on
right now with residential schools and
stuff like it's important that we
learned this language because our
ancestors couldn't the organization
provides a range of programming
preserving and teaching the languages of
cree ojibwe ojibwe cree dene dakota
mischief and inuit really just provide
opportunities to develop speakers
because
there aren't
many left in the larger scheme of things
and we really need to develop speakers
before
we lose
our elders who are there too
to guide us through that five none in
guiding future generations i know that
i need to make sure that
i do everything i can to keep our
languages
alive and going to stay connected to
their roots
and to this land marnie blunt global
news winnipeg
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is ladner bc which was originally
a fishing village on the fraser river we
would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you